oh wow this is hitting something in me
that I've never felt before and it's
kind of a shame today we are trying
weird massage products that you can buy
on Amazon I've never gotten a massage in
my life actually love massages give
massage probably once a month it's like
my self-care routine I have like very
tensed shoulders my shoulders just feel
really like gross I just feel like sore
all the time I don't know if this is
going to be really weird or if these are
actually going to be good products so we
have to see
[Music]
okay I definitely thought this is a
poppet
it looks like one of those like little
things that you do math on this is like
what do you think maybe it's for like
your neck or something like this just
feels like I'm kind of like making pizza
out of my thigh okay I see I see what's
happening here you got me you gotten
drill bit it does feel good oh I think
that's what it is you need to flex your
muscle while you do it okay
yeah like it like loosens up your
muscles it's good
Oh hand massage her this is so cute this
looks like like a alien or something got
some little cool Rolly balls okay so I'm
guessing you put your hand inside he
likens it like so and you bring it up to
you and you just go at it and just feels
like I'm running something like Hot
Wheels cars on my legs I feel like you
could shower with this like put a little
soap on these balls I would love this if
somebody uses it on me I don't
necessarily need to use it on somebody
else I'm selfish
oh yeah that's so nice but that's cuz
you're doing it for me I would
definitely buy this but I would also
need a boyfriend too
[Music]
okay first and foremost trigger trigger
therapy massage it look at these
instructions I hate reading instructions
[Music]
well okay what is this okay
I mean it feels like nice I mean like I
like ooh that's good right there oh this
looks like a contraption that killed the
mighty way this is an effective and
nothing nothing about this I mean I'm
just gonna [ __ ] that and just do my own
thing ooh you just have all these little
pressure points little bumps that you
can apply to pressure points and get rid
of any if this feels good to you just
[ __ ] use an umbrella
[Music]
is this for my butt left cheek right
cheek no this getting high-tech okay
whoever's uses her teeth is like a coil
spot so I feel like they put their face
on it what do I do with this like this
[Applause]
this is so hypnotic anyway I'm gonna put
it on my ass now okay let's let's try it
out okay oh wow I don't know my lower
back I don't know I just feel like
someone would definitely call HR if I
was like constantly using this at my
desk I feel like any privacy honest
moments if this isn't that expensive
this is almost as good as a much massage
chair
[Music]
this thing looks like a cast member of
stranger things I don't know what
happening this is something this is
intense
hello yes Karen is that you oh okay all
right let's go oh snap it's the kind of
rough but it kind of like it okay chill
chill chill chill you don't even need
anyone you could be alone for the rest
of your life if you have this if I had
it plugged in next to my bed just like
at night like before I go to bed the
only issue about this machine is it's
like really loud so like if you have
roommates their parents everyone's gonna
know you're going at it as soon as you
turn this on there I got Herricks
massaging again honestly after trying
all of these massage products I feel a
lot more stressed out I feel very
anxious I feel really relaxed right now
I'm gonna take a nap my favorite is that
little ghost hand thing or that old
alien looking thing the last two are the
ones that work the best my favorite one
was that bought one not for my butt
although once in a while like it really
did help like I'm not even slight that
was really great whatever I'll try
anything once they'll go get some
massages but these are okay to hold you
over to your next one the things the
Internet can do it's incredible
[Music]
[Music]